la plage des paniers les vacanciers
c'est l'image traditionnelle de la côte
d'azur
mais depuis quelques années la ville de
nice met les bouchées doubles pour être
aussi reconnue comme la ville la plus
verte de francs comme la pelouse
naturelle du nouveau stade de la ville
arrosé à l'eau de pluie récupérée grâce
à un ingénieux système de tubulures l'
architecture originale se distingue par
sa charpente en bois
la température y est régulée grâce à un
savant système d'échangé thermique
mettant à profit les vent et l'eau de la
nappe phréatique
la véritable particularité du stade se
trouve sur le toit qui abrite une
véritable petite centrale électrique
quatre mille panneaux solaires qui
produisent trois fois plus d'énergie que
ce que consomme le stade en termes
d'efficacité énergétique
le stade de nice est citée en exemple je
crois qu'il n'y a pas d'autres exemples
d'infrastructure où il ya une telle
concentration de préoccupation
développement durable donc je pense que
ce bâtiment à vocation à faire des
émules
l'exemple peut-être suis iwuy à quelques
kilomètres de là un autobus unique au
monde sert de navette à l'aéroport de
nice côte d'azur
s'il apparaît normal au premier regard
ces déplacements silencieux et son bras
articulé ne trompe pas c'est un autobus
électriques
un prototype testé ici en conditions
réelles
c'est un véhicule qu'on appelle à
biberonnage parce que pour pas emporter
des tonnes et des tonnes de batteries en
emporte des toutes petites et des super
condensateurs déstockeurs d'énergie un
petit peu hybride l'autobus à une très
faible autonomie
une quarantaine de kilomètres à peine
sur ses batteries de secours
mais le système de recharge rapide lui
donne dans les faits une autonomie
illimitée
à chaque arrêt l'autobus potet si chargé
en énergie c'est super condensateurs en
une vingtaine de secondes lui permettant
de se rendre prochaine mais sans
utiliser sa batterie un système plus
cher à l'achat que le diesel mais qui
pourrait être amorti en 10 ans grâce aux
économies de carburant et surtout c'est
beaucoup moins polluant on a avec ce
système là en service commercial 85% du
co2 du puits à la roue qui économisait
ce n'est là qu'un des multiples projets
verts mis de l'avant par l'est au port
de nice qui s'est donné pour objectif
d'être neutre en carbone d'ici 2018
alimenté à 100 % énergies vertes
il produira bientôt plus d'électricité
qu'il n'en consomme grâce à des panneaux
solaires installés dans un nouveau
terminal l'objectif faire rimer économie
et écologie
un kilowatt économiser ses d euros
économisés essais des gaz à effet serre
noémie donc on est dans une
problématique où tout le monde est
gagnant reste bien sûr le problème du
carbone émis par les avions eux mêmes la
solution viendra probablement un jour
des biocarburants produits à base
d'algues et d'huiles végétales sans
doute le prochain défi de l'industrie du
transport aérien
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
nice